well the lessons are that we do all of
us France and Britain other European
countries we have a fifth column within
our country it's mercifully small but
it's there and we need to be far more
robust in terms of how we deal with
radical preaching inside the mosques and
I think also in presenting the Dean of
the vision of who we are as a country
what we stand for to provide people
perhaps with better alternatives so I'm
personally very keen to stop much of the
funding that is coming for British
mosques and into universities from Saudi
Arabia and externally I mean look lots
of people have been warning over the
last six months that if you are prepared
to accept you send that message
countless millions of people from over
the Mediterranean and through the
Western Balkans that when Isis say they
will use this to flood the continent
with their jihadists they probably mean
it and I'm just amazed today that
Monsieur alarmed and indeed mr. Janka
have made it clear that they intend to
continue with a migrant policy which
says that anybody that sets foot on EU
soil can stay and I think that is really
very very dangerously complacent you're
actually saying are you not that you
believe Britain's membership of the EU
is endangering our national security I
do I'm with the Prime Minister launched
his so-called renegotiation last week
the big new theme was security we're
much more secure and safe inside the
European Union indeed he used the word
security 34 times in his speech I think
it's pretty clear that with mrs. Merkel
having sent out the call for as many
people to come as possible with no
checks no vetting being done on people's
backgrounds that within a very short
time many of the people coming to
Germany will have German passports EU
passports and can then come to Britain
and I think to protect national security
getting back control of our borders is
absolutely vital and we cannot do that
unless we vote to leave the European
Union why do we not have control of our
borders after all we haven't had
refugees getting into Britain as they
have into continental Europe and indeed
the French have cooperated in
maintaining a border at
the coast of with the English Channel
well I mean our situation is better than
Frances that's for certain I mean
somebody can drive into Romania with the
boot full of Kalashnikovs cross every
border go straight to Paris without any
point in time the report while sitting
upon time making is it is this isn't
really a european union issue as far as
britain's concerned because we already
have control of those borders no it is a
european at union issue once the people
that come get european union passports
which can happen in a very short period
of time we are not we are not isolated
from this in any way at all let alone
the fact that we know that illegal
immigration to Britain is still
continuing through Calais and elsewhere
if we want to be safe we want to be
secure we must have control of our
borders at the moment anybody with an EU
passport and that's nearly half a
billion people can come to Britain
without any background checks being
needed at all Jeremy Corbyn has said
tonight that he's not comfortable with
the idea of a shoot-to-kill policy
Islamic terrorists if they are
identified in the UK what's your view of
that my view is that I wish that the
home secretary and Prime Minister would
be stronger but it is clear that the
leader of the Opposition just does not
take Islamic terrorism seriously and
isn't prepared to lift a finger to do
anything about it we face a genuine
crisis here there are people in our
midst that want to destroy our
civilization we have got to stand up and
protect what is ours mr corbyn won't do
it but the truth is that Britain
fortunately has not had a major
terrorist Institute incident for 10
years now why do you think that is well
I think we have probably better
intelligence than the French have and
that's why when the government asks for
more powers you know provided there is
some judicial oversight I have to say I
suppose it I wouldn't have done years
ago but I understand the need for it so
I do think that we have a better
intelligence service I also think the
fact that we are able to
stop people who come from outside the
European Union is also a massive asset
to us doesn't doesn't insulate us
completely from these great problems but
it does leave us in a better position
than EU countries that are part of the
Schengen area and thank goodness we
didn't join the Schengen area